when we represent information such as an
image digitally it means we must slice
it up into tiny chunks this allows us to
send an image as a sequence of color
symbols and these colors can be
represented as unique numbers using some
code
consider the following challenge Alice
and Bob can transmit and receive
messages in binary they charge their
customers one penny per bit to use their
system and a regular customer arrives
who wants to send a message and their
messages are 1,000 symbols long the
meaning of the messages is completely
unknown normally this is sent with a
standard two-bit code which results in
charging for 2,000 bits
however Alice and Bob already did some
analysis on this customer before and
determined that the probability of each
symbol in the message is different can
they use these known probabilities to
compress the transmission and increase
their profits what's the optimal coding
strategy David Huffman famously provided
the optimal strategy which he published
in 1952 and based on building a binary
tree from the bottom up to begin we can
list all symbols at the bottom which we
can call nodes and then we find the two
least probable nodes in this case B and
C and merge them into one and add the
probabilities together then we repeat
with the next two least likely notes and
continue merging until you have a single
node at the top finally we label the
edges in this tree with 0 or 1 in any
order
now the code for each letter is just the
path from the top of the tree to the
given letter
so for a it's just one edge or one this
is now known as a Huffman coding and for
examples of the following type you
cannot beat it go ahead and try for
example if you shorten the code for d2
just zero then a message zero one one
could perhaps mean deed a a or maybe
just B so for this to work you'd need to
introduce letter spaces which cancel out
any savings during transmission now how
far does this compress the message
compared to the original 2,000 bits well
we just need to calculate the number of
bits per letter on average so we
multiply the length of each code times
the probability of occurence and add
them together which results in an
average length of 1.75 bits per symbol
on average that means with this Huffman
coding we can expect to compress the
messages from 2,000 bits to 1,750 bits
and Claude Shannon was the first to
claim that the limit of compression will
always be the entropy of the message
source
as the entropy or uncertainty of our
source decreases due to known
statistical structure the ability to
compress increases while if the entropy
increases due to unpredictability our
ability to compress decreases if we want
to compress beyond entropy we must
necessarily throw away information in
our messages